let's try answering an easier form of the problem. This might help us think about
what we should do. How many batches of brownies could you bake if a recipe
requires 1/2 of a cup of sugar and you have one cup of sugar at home? This seems
a little bit easier. This square is going to represent my one cup of sugar. I
know 1/2 of a cup of sugar will make one batch of brownies. So I'm going to fill
up 1/2 of my cup and make one batch of brownies. So here's a half cup of sugar
and I know I made one batch of brownies. If I use another half cup of sugar, I
know I'll make another batch of brownies. Now I've used my one whole cup of
sugar and I don't have any sugar left at home. Well, I made two batches of
brownies. Let's try this with some math. I have one cup of sugar. And I wondered
how many times did 1/2 go into it? I knew I was able to make 2 batches of
brownies. So 1 divided by a 1/2 must be 2. Remember, when we divide by a number,
we can actually multiply by the reciporical. We learned that from before. So I
could change this to look like 1 times 2 over 1. Well, remember, I could just
put any number over 1. And then, multiply fractions like before. 1 times 2 is 2,
and 1 times 1 is 1. 2 for 1 is just 2. Let's change this problem a little bit
and see what we can find out. What if instead a recipe called for 1/3 a cup of
sugar? I know if I use a 3rd cup of sugar I'll make one batch of brownies. If I
use another 1/3 cup of sugar, I'll make another batch of brownies and if I use
my last 1/3 cup of sugar I'll make one more batch of brownies. So let's put this
with some math. I was wondering how many times does 1/3 go into 1 so I did 1
divided by 1/3. I know that for every 1/3 cup of sugar I get one batch of
brownies so I should get three batches. Remember when I divide by a number it's
the same thing as multiply by the reciprocal. I could change this to
multiplication 1 times 3 over 1. I know 1 is just 1 over 1 and now I can
multiply these fractions together. 1 times 3 is 3 and 1 times 1 is 1, I get 3
over 1, 3 divided by 1 is 3 batches. I hope you're starting to see a pattern.
Let's see if you can figure this one out.